I think this is going to be a really
exciting video because today we are
going to generate some random numbers
with strontium-90
radioactive strontium monkey I find all
of this quite unnerving because this
stuff is dangerous you have to really
respect it it will hurt you let's do
you've asked me to generate for you a
random number right and I'm going to I
want to throw that straight back at you
I want to play a game actually what I
want you to do all of you everybody
right you're watching everybody I want
you to clear your head for a moment and
I want you to think of a random number
from one to ten got it okay
choose a number between one and ten - I
tell you it okay two six seven choose a
number between one and ten so nine seven
seven is more likely to be chosen and I
know I'm annoyed that I pick seven
actually 45% of you are going to have
said seventh choose and it told me a
number between one and ten seven seven
everybody says seven obviously you're
not going to choose one or ten because
that's not very random right you're not
going to choose an even number because
they don't sound particularly random
either and you're going to go for five
because fives in the middle he'll that's
not random so you probably want a prime
number so nines out three is too small
freeze like you're not trying you
haven't worked hard enough to get to it
so what you're left with you're left
with seven so everybody chooses seven so
is there something innately random about
the number seven now of course not
that's that's ridiculous there's nothing
random about any number right if I said
to you pick a random number and you said
five how do I know that's random if I
asked you to do it again you came up
with five again and again and again
clearly that's not a random number the
property that makes a number random
isn't in the number itself but it's in
the sequence of numbers right any
individual number isn't random one is
the number one random it entirely
depends on the context right just one on
its own there's nothing random about
but if I have one five two eight seven
four is one random yes one is a random
part of that sequence or at least it's
as random as the human mind can make it
which as we've just seen from our little
game it isn't particularly random at all
as a scientist right I model gases and
as a part of modeling gases I need to
give them a random kick to get them
started so that I don't model an
identical gas every time I can't go
through and and give each molecule a
random value from my own mind I use a
computer to choose my random numbers and
it's spectacularly bad at doing that no
chance of getting a computer to generate
a completely random sequence but it's
not a random machine we have to generate
a sequence of numbers which look and
feel random to us right but they're not
random if we look closely enough we're
always going to find patterns so the
easiest way to go about doing this can I
write this down let me write this down
typically the way that a computer
engineer is going to go about generating
a sequence of random numbers for you is
to think of a number right and we'll
just call that number X naught our first
number in the sequence or a zeros number
in the sequence and we're going to
multiply that number by something big
something that feels random okay and
we're going to call that rather
unimpressive ly a typically it's going
to be something of the order of tens of
thousands at this point there's
absolutely nothing random about this
whatsoever
I'm going to take another big prime
number in the tens of thousands and
we're going to add it on and with a
spectacular lack of imagination I'm
going to call that big still not random
I know it's not random the next step is
probably the only complicated bit is I'm
going to take the number that we've just
got and I'm going to do a modulus which
we normally define as just being a % and
and as a cyclic division so essentially
it's the remainder of a divide so if I
were for example to use M of 8 if I do a
cyclic division of 64 divided by 8 I get
0 if I use 66 divided by 8 I'm going to
get 2 it's the remainder of that
division so you make this big
and then you do that process to it using
this number correct so you must still
get the same number every time you still
get the same number absolutely every
time and the answer we're going to uni
call sign in here what we get out of
here is the next number in a sequence X
1 then I'm going to take X 1 and I'm
going to feed it back in and we're going
to use that to generate X 2 and then I'm
going to feed that back in and generate
X 3 so I get a sequence of numbers that
feel like they might be random but if I
were to start with X of 0 then I'm
always going to get an identical
sequence so if I'm going to write a
piece of software where I want a random
sequence
I need the value of X naught to be
different every time you know if I if I
keep my computer off again I need it to
be in a different state to start with
and I mean the most obvious way of doing
that and the way I do that is I simply
use the time I use the number of
milliseconds since January 1970 and then
I'm going to feed that into X naught and
then X 1 is different X 2 is different X
3 is different but and this is the
important thing because this is a cyclic
division it's going to eventually repeat
and depending on which numbers you
choose for a and B and M it will repeat
sooner rather than later you're going to
get cyclic patterns in your random
numbers so we don't call these random
numbers we call these pseudo random
numbers because they're kind of random
they're not really random we can do
better than that though right ok so if
you ask me to generate a random number
let's go back to the game we played at
the start right now I'm going to say
let's generate a random number this time
between 1 & 6
there's a really obvious way of doing
that I bought a dice with me we throw it
and we generate a random number and each
of those numbers 1 to 6 has the same
probability of coming up but that's not
always true what if I want to generate a
number between 1 and 12 let me get
another dice first of all I can't
generate or one with two dice I
recognize that so it's going to be a
number between 2 and 12 okay we throw
that we get 6 there
many many more ways to throw a seven
than there are to throw a two there's
only one way I can throw it to it I've
got a three double one if I want to
throw a 12 I've got a three double six
but I can throw seven with a three and a
four or a 4 and a 3 or a 5 and a 2 or a
601 there's loads of ways to do that so
you're far more likely let me draw this
for you for one dice this probability is
the same and it's one SiC but for two
days then you're going to get a
probability which is quite sharply
peaked what if I bought more dice out or
just throw three so now okay so now
we're throwing that's random right well
done so now I'm going to throw three
dice and what we find is that we get a
similar plot but it starts to curve over
like this so we can go from three up to
18 what we're starting to produce is a
thing called a Gaussian distribution a
normal distribution it's called normal
because almost everything in nature does
this right if there's some probability
distribution which is based on dice or
based on the probability of the behavior
of lots of things which are behaving
identically then you get a Gaussian
distribution so it's absolutely
everywhere and a Gaussian distribution
as a shape which looks a bit like this
and it's very sharply peaked you're very
very likely to get this average value
but it's still completely random okay I
can't tell you what value I'm going to
get all I can tell you is the
probability of that bad you don't want
to hear about the ancient Greeks do
we've flown - we've thrown three now
I've bought frankly every day so I own
and we're going to throw many dice and
when we throw many some of them go on
the floor but what we end up with is
this Gaussian distribution the
probability of the number that we're
going to get is the Gaussian
distribution so what most people think
of as a random number is actually a
uniform deviate which basically means
that every number in the sequence has
got the same chance of coming up right
but that doesn't make it random what
makes it random is that you can choose
any number in the sequence it doesn't
matter what the probability of that
choice is so you may have you may be
very very likely to choose the number in
the middle but that doesn't mean that
it's not randomly possible for you to
choose any number at all so it's like if
you and I had a weightlifting
competition the result will be random
but you're probably going to win that's
not random
no you misunderstand I'm going to win
that one you've asked me to to give you
a random number and I really want to so
so I've kind of gone out of my way and
I've gone to the safe and I've got
something that's going to create a
random number because here I've got a
small radioactive source which
strontium-90 and it is going to randomly
give out electrons okay as a neutron
turned into a proton and out comes a
high energy electron from the strontium
and so coming into the Geiger counter
here I'm getting just a steady stream of
electrons and counting them and the
number that I count surprise-surprise is
gaussian right but it's random it's
completely random and so though let's
turn it on let me just show you can I
show you that's the happy sound of
radiation so you can hear it but you can
see it - here it is
here are the individual pulses each one
of these flashing on here that's an
electron going into the Geiger counter
which is pretty cool so I've written you
a small computer program I hope it works
the number you're going to get is the
deviation from the mean value so I know
what the mean value for the count is
going to be and I'm giving you the
difference between that value and
number we actually count here we go well
I was expecting it to be a little more
dramatic than that what that means is
we've got we've got exactly the mean
value right so that is the most likely
outcome and yet somehow I didn't expect
that that was going to be actually try
again we're generating another random
number and to be honest I really want it
to be seven so this is it counting 13 is
prime
how much more random do you want to be
right that's a spectacular random number
it's 13 brilliant
so if you enjoyed this video I've got
some good news for you we're actually
starting a new channel a bit like
numberphile but all about computers it's
something a lot of you have asked about
that channel is going to be launching
properly in May but we've started it now
and you can go and have a look and
subscribe I'll put a link on the screen
underneath the video and in the video
description all that sort of thing have
a look and we hope to see you there too